hey what's up guys mkbhd here as you
probably already know i love youtube and
a lot of other people do
i upload videos here all the time i
leave thumbs up on videos all the time
and i interact in the comments section
of youtube all the time and a lot of
people also do the same thing so
billions and billions of views are
constantly served on youtube on the last
count more than 200 million people use
youtube on mobile devices every single
day which means that 200 million people
or so every day use the youtube app on
their smartphone or their tablet to get
to this website now this is a pretty
good app and a lot of people have a lot
of good things to say about it but there
are also some things that are very very
major features of youtube that are
missing from the youtube app so without
any further ado let's take a look at
three huge things that would make the
youtube mobile app a lot better number
one is annotations annotations like
these if you don't know what they are
now if you're viewing this on a mobile
device you won't be seeing what i'm
pointing at i look like a crazy person
but there are annotations if you watch
this on a desktop and these can actually
be very important in a lot of cases a
lot of youtubers have an end screen at
the end of their videos just like i do
where they have a clickable link to
subscribe to their channel or a
clickable link to a related one of the
videos that they've uploaded sometimes
you might be talking about a very
important cause and you want to include
a clickable link inside the video that
you point at just like that where it
leads to an external site or maybe you
might make a mistake during the video
and you need to correct yourself so you
add an annotation with some text in it
to clarify what your mistake was and how
to correct it so a lot of times
annotations are really important to the
context of a video and that's not
available at all in any way on mobile so
that is a huge improvement right there
that could be awesome annotations for
youtube mobile second up is the comment
system on youtube comments are a huge
part of youtube besides giving videos
thumbs up you can actually interact with
people and talk about and discuss the
video by leaving comments by replying to
comments all sorts of things like that i
would love on the youtube mobile app to
be able to view the top rated comments
to be able to see how many thumbs up
those comments got to be able to rate
comments to be able to reply to comments
and to be able to get notifications of
comments there's actually no inbox
functionality whatsoever on the youtube
mobile app there is a inbox on the
youtube mobile site but that is the
mobile website which you have to access
using the browser it's not in the
youtube mobile app so there's no
notification whatsoever if someone
replies to one of your comments and even
if they do and you do see it you can't
reply back because there's no reply
button so the whole comment system on
youtube is very very limited all you can
do on the mobile app is view all the
comments on a video and leave one of
your own if you want which is a step in
the right direction but it would be
awesome to be able to have all the
features that are available on the
youtube desktop site on the mobile app
and number three is all the little
things there are plenty of little things
that do exist on the desktop and even in
the mobile website but that don't exist
on the app you might have noticed when i
talked about google plus which has an
excellent mobile app it's so good
because a lot of the features almost all
the features available on the desktop
are available on the app and that's why
the app is so good with the service
youtube not so much for example like i
mentioned there's no inbox functionality
so no alerts no notifications nothing it
is also the ability to create playlists
but once you do you can't edit them you
can view a user's channel just like you
can on the desktop but unlike the
desktop on the app you can't search
through the users uploads you can even
view the list of all the channels you're
subscribed to on the left hand side but
you can't search through these either
you can't browse through the most viewed
or most discussed or top rated videos of
the day week or month like you can on
the desktop and the search filter is
extremely diluted let me tell you why on
the desktop you can sort when you search
so you can sort by relevance or by
upload date or by view count or by
rating and you can filter these sorted
results by videos only or channels only
or playlists only or if you want movies
only or tv shows only and you can also
sort by duration or by resolution so you
can even sort from highest rated or
lowest rated or most popular all sorts
of things you can sort by and that makes
it a very very precise search especially
if you want to find a specific video or
a specific topic or category of videos
on the mobile app you get a channels
only or videos only filter and you get a
very basic date uploaded filter that's
it so that would be a huge improvement
they can make right there and last but
not least in the android app if you
perform search number one and then
perform search number two and then hit
the back button you end up back at the
home page
where'd search number one go even the
categories are a little bit out of place
in order to sort just videos by category
you have to scroll down all the way past
all of the names of all your
subscriptions to get to the bottom of
that list which is where you can sort by
category which is really really
inconvenient they could probably change
the order of that if they were thinking
through it a little bit so what do we
learn from this well some things can be
you know really beautiful really good
looking or really smooth and can seem to
just work
but if they're lacking functionality
then you have to wonder if it's really
all that great and that applies to more
than just the youtube mobile app but you
guys already knew that either way thanks
for watching this video hope you guys
give a thumbs up if you agree with this
and hopefully some of these changes are
made i really want to see the comments
section beefed up be really awesome in
the new youtube app but either way
thanks for watching and i'll talk to you
guys in the next video
peace
so
you